[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Give me a minute,
and I'll show you how
Compute Engine can
help you move existing
workloads to Google Cloud.
Compute Engine delivers
scannable and high performance
virtual machines running
in Google's data centers.
You can select the right
machine for your needs
from predefined or
custom machine types.
It's easy-- just select
the type of machine
and where you want it.
Choose general purpose machines
for apps, databases, and web
servers, or memory
optimized machines
for in-memory databases, SAP
HANA, and real-time analytics.
Or compute optimized machines
for high performance computing,
financial modeling,
gaming, and RGPUs
to accelerate computationally
intensive workloads
like machine learning
or medical analysis.
Using Compute Engine, you can
live migrate between hosts
without rebooting.
This keeps your apps running,
even during maintenance.
It provides right
size recommendations
so you can resize your machine
type depending on your usage.
You pay for what you use, and
you can increase those savings
by applying committed use
and sustained use discounts.
For further savings,
check out Preemptible VMs.
These are low-cost, short-term
instances suited for batch jobs
and fault tolerant workloads.
Use Compute Engine to
migrate your existing systems
into Google Cloud,
run databases,
do financial modeling, or
even run Windows workloads.
Next time you're
thinking about migrating
your apps to the cloud
quickly, take a minute
to look at Compute Engine.
For more info, check out
cloud.google.com/compute.